[Music]
some days
it was a sunrise so bold and golden it
didn't seem real
another it was a bottle of champagne a
young mom handed me
near the edge of crater lake the next
discovering a cooler someone had left
out near the edge of lava fields in
southern oregon
filled with the makings of rippier
floats
these were moments i experienced as a
backpacker on the pacific crest trail
and moments that i quickly learned
hikers dubbed trail magic
these were moments that connected me to
natural beauty and to the new friends
that i was hiking with
moments that brought me into the present
and sparked a grateful
deep breath yes i have hundreds of
brutal miles ahead of me
for right now i'm thankful for this
moment
when i came off the trail and returned
to my laptop i wondered
could i find the same feeling surrounded
by responsibilities and the daily grind
could this feeling be scaled across
spaces communities and careers
figuring this out is important because a
lot of us here
are trying to solve hard problems for me
that's solving climate change but
whether we're solving a structural
problem
or just taking on the challenges of life
it can be
an emotional exhausting slog
that requires a touch of this magic to
get through
today i want to share with you first the
elements that make up trail magic
and the positive psychology behind this
feeling
second why trail magic isn't just for
hikers
and third how we can create more of this
for ourselves
and for others this curious phenomenon
has its roots in america's oldest
backpacking communities
every year since the 1950s hundreds of
backpackers have trekked
2600 miles from mexico to canada on the
pacific crest trail
the pct for four months
they hike 30 miles a day across snow
packs deserts and towns
my sister was crazy enough to do this
and i was crazy enough to
follow her for a month for us this
adventure meant
long days and endless blisters it meant
eating cold mashed potatoes and tuna on
repeat
it meant weathering injuries and
hitchhiking into towns
but i quickly noticed that amidst these
challenging lows
hikers made the most of the highs
they received any beautiful moment in
nature or
unexpected act of kindness with a
heightened sense of wonder
and gratitude trail magic
one moment while i was hiking captured
the essence of this
it was somewhere in the timberline
wilderness and we were up at 4
and hiking by 5am with headlamps and a
plan to hike 27
miles that day but around 1 pm we
stumbled upon a middle-aged couple
grilling by the trail instead of
powering on we spent hours
in the present eating burgers and
hearing about their retirement plans
this experience had the four hallmarks
of trail magic
it connected me to others it shifted my
perspective
into the present it sparked gratitude
and it surprised me connection
perspective gratitude and surprise
this magic may sound ephemeral but it's
actually neurological
trail magic is built on gratitude which
researchers from ucla
and upenn have proven increases
serotonin
dopamine and pro-social behavior in
short the appreciation of trail magic
makes us happy
it sparks a jolt of neurotransmitters
which increase
our well-being and our empathy
surprisingly trail magic also changes
our perception of time
how many of you have felt like your time
is precious
or in short supply see some nods and
same and we're not alone according to a
recent gallup poll of a thousand
americans
almost half felt that they didn't lack
or that they lacked enough time
in daily life the good news is that
researchers have found
that experiencing awe changes our
perception of time
both awe and trail magic are
characterized by a wonder
and gratitude that brings perspective
and as we shift into the present
psychologically
time stretches it makes us feel like we
have
more time available some of you are
saying
i love the outdoors i'll look for this
next time i'm there
but i bet a few of you are thinking i am
the opposite of outdoorsy
c'est la vie no magic for me but i
disagree
according to the environmental
protection agency the average american
spends 93
of her time indoors or in a car
but we can find trail magic during our
time outside and during
all of this time inside
when i finished my 500th mile my dad
picked me up on the side of the highway
the dirt had bled
permanently into the white trim of my
black running shorts
muscles i didn't know i had were sore
but i was radiant
i felt strong having completed a section
of the pct
and privileged to have that opportunity
i felt more connected than ever to the
oregon landscape
and to the crazier hikers with crazier
names that i had met along the way
fancy mac macgyver coconut
blasting oldies and flying down i-5 i
saw the bars grow
on the edge of my phone as we came back
into service range
as i went to call my partner alex a text
came through
can we talk and i knew
the car at 70 miles per hour stood still
and my heart froze as my mind spun
into a kaleidoscope of the pain and
hospital appointments
coming for the person i loved the most
his cancer was back
the levity and perspective i'd felt
earlier that very morning
seemed as distant as the oregon cascades
in our rearview mirror
trail magic felt ephemeral and rapidly
evaporating
but over the next year i was surprised
to find it again
in the friendship that we built with our
nurse dana
in the time the hospital snacks
spontaneously upgraded to graham
crackers
and saving our favorite show to watch
every week during alex's treatment
being open to these small moments of
magic and holding on tight
gave us a mini umbrella in the rain and
the energy
to take on the next year
what i'm saying is that i found trail
magic off the trail and it was powerful
a temporary antidote to worrying about
the future
a pause in relentless productivity a
celebration
in miniature of what matters
i remember when i was a kid and disney
was gospel and embraced magic like my
best friend
someone told me you have the power to
fly just jump and i did
but actually my sister told me that if i
jumped out of a tree with an umbrella
i could float just like jiminy cricket
so i jumped
and the ground came fast as i grew up i
learned skepticism and
injustice believing in magic felt
indulgent next to so many adult worries
and systems to dismantle
and as a productive professional i
didn't have time for it
but i missed that self that found wonder
in everything
and delight in the small things
i'm asking us to be open once again to
that feeling
of magic specifically the connection
perspective gratitude and surprise
of trail magic
surprising ourselves is tricky but
i'll give a few tactical ideas for how
we can discover this phenomenon
more often for ourselves first
celebrate those small moments the
unexpected burgers or the hospital
snacks
second take a risk and initiate a new
connection
maybe it's in a zoom chat or an uber or
the checkout line of a grocery store
i have to say that after a few years in
consulting i'd forgotten some of this i
used to fly every week for work
and i remember using every second on the
on the plane to fervently make slides
the pinnacle of efficiency but one
monday
mid-flight my laptop battery died and i
looked up
i started chatting with my seat mate a
hawaiian volcanologist
two hours later i had learned basic
volcanic geology
and the names of her kids jennifer and
sam
so the secret to finding trail magic
more often for yourselves
celebrate the small moments and
channel your six-year-old point of view
at this point a few of the entrepreneurs
in the audience might be asking
themselves
so can this idea scale and the answer is
absolutely and exponentially we can
amplify trail magic by creating it for
others
i already see this happening in our
community and i would love to see it
happen more
one friend then owed me money for a
drink while i was on vacation
just because another
wrote holiday notes to her favorite
baristas
trail magic doesn't have to be
complicated or
expensive just unexpected and
compassionate
the possibilities are endless but i'll
share a few of my favorites
if a friend mentions an important date
that's coming up
put a reminder on your calendar to reach
out then
treat the person behind you in line at
koopa to coffee
professionally unprompted think of two
people on your network with shared
interests that you think
would hit it off let's make this common
practice
starting today think of a gesture
have a rip your float sometimes grab
your umbrella and your six-year-old
point of view
the world will be a bit more magical
because you did